beh ragazzi bene dove sono e sono file
già oggi siamo con il nostro amico
pietro per il nostro ma scusami
aspettami mela è nato infatti pato può
fare uniti perche la morte di penso io
chi pensa ci penso ex dorato qua ecco mi
prese che aumenta che non so dove sei il
materiale non sono un po più in alto ma
non a tale uso devo fare quale sta
diventando sempre più difficile capire
cosa di vibonati
no non è quando c'è uno sla in giù e
siccome bisogna fare questo spesso
guardano non lo so ci provo però
potrebbe guardare la gloria eterna
mumbai mato però me lo meritavo me lo
meritavo per la per la temerarietà non
si diceva forse l'emergenza ma comica
per essere stato temerario è quello no e
no aspettami che non funziona perché no
ho provato e l'ho fatto ma non arrivi a
dove non ci arrivi no da vuol dire
questa frase non cerri binomio abbiamo
visto e si no ho visto sono partito dal
più alto e non ci arrivi anche charlie
mischiata è tacco
non so come vanno ci sei arrivato prima
bellissimo attenzione poi bellissimo
indietro amiche bellissimo aspetta
aspetta aspetta un fortissimo questo
party notare una cosa come mai tu c'hai
il livello 36 al 30
adesso mi hanno preso il checkpoint
penser check points e mori è un casino
all'acqua fermo che quello lo slime
guardato rito subito ormai 200 i pacchi
ne sappia novecento in cui 200 però ho
sbagliato la giocata amiche non fosse
esattamente alle cene l'ho fatto l'ho
fatto dalla strada lato e come come
risalgo comiche non posso dire che mi
sono bloccato e anche io aspettai no
sono proprio bloccato amiche non posso
dire che io aspetto il porco demonio
come si fa a non scendere nei buchi ma
nomi che non posso tornare su un prato
tornare anche volendo asi hanno no si
può fare di quali quali qua te devi
scendere mentre ne dubito è riuscito no
perché è bloccato ahi ahi ahi ahi altro
volendo parlando però che c'è una volta
ce l'ha fatto parte ma si entra fino a
un altro che succede cosa succede è
uguale uguale è uguale non cambia niente
sono tutte uguali ma quel labirinto
buonissimo ragata ammucchia nissimo non
lo so 39 se lo fai tanta tv passare
tutto sotto c'è tutto un livello che
devi fare arrivederci
aspettami vado a pisciare vado sul serio
a pisciare io faccio livello in tanto
bene ma come cacchio è fatta la rivale
ii 1 portassimo a un attimo ma questo
cieco ma cosa devo fare qua mar le parti
giunsero a c'era una porta ai fatti
se tutto ciò è adesso lo faccio senza
sapere cosa ti volevo mai a fare i seri
ma tu l'hai fatto quanto già dimessa
passava 10 quando si può prendere il
secchio dell'acqua che vedo lì non credo
cioè sì si può prendere ma non è lecito
farlo ma c'è un portale al net e c'è uno
sprone e dove camper e vabbè minchia
dallo sfondo di farti quel salvalai
capitolo a parte da non ho capito meglio
cos'è e dai cioè allora o sei tu scusa
superiore mi chiamo così la t a chi fa e
facendo il parco non si può fare che si
può fare basta crederci raggiungere
l'amico tenuto fortissimo da mary ha un
motivo uno sarò uno soltanto il motivo
una volta che ho fatto fare un sacco di
visco l'italia litigio spina di ghiaccio
amiche non è finita come no ma mi chiedo
ma basta no non ci credo dai come e cosa
ci sta dicendo niente
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
che sarà
non è finita pensavo fosse finito tutto
mannaggia che sfiga abbiamo ancora solo
60 livelli non siamo neanche a metà non
siamo neanche a metà a metà le a metà
set seguita la mappa come cacchio
facciamo le diceva ti rendi conto il
problema deve saltare no no no no no no
no no no amiche no ho capito è esatto su
quello grigio che sinistra che oggi è
più alto vai dritto per dritto
bravissime ma da qualche anno fa o a
caso il 2000 e cupla madonna non ci
sarei mai rimane nella mente ci salita
ma un altro valido motivo
vale
ok successo ma che cazzo ne so a occhio
perché se schiacci di tasti muori ok ok
ottenuti zitti zitti
ha sbagliato bellissimo bellissimo
bellissimo ok ok madonna che provata
finito o infinito
ti giuro aspetta che non capisco madonna
stavo cadendo stavo cadendo con un salto
ridicolo ce l'ho fatta cioè 42 ma come è
veramente facile amiche dai questori
veramente ridicolo dai uno scherzo
ovvero la lav ha appena nata vero ma
mike ma lasciamo perdere stai cagate
grazie a michele non so cosa devo fare
qua non lo so
cioè unico yahoo che ha di nuovo dori
cambiata la proposta fatta grazie grazie
grazie grazie di male chi male aspetta
che qualcuno le mani e culo bene di dio
cioè quanto nodo porca [ __ ] secondo
quanto cosa ma vasta sinuosi ma io non
mi riconosco non so che ma che cazzo
servono scusa delle cento della fina
mano
no non ho fatto io che non dicono e
comoda come questa board penso fosse
finito due che sono da sei fermo porco
del demonio fermo non ci ma mi stai
picchiando slime più uscita che non è
così difficile non è così difficile
l'ho già fatto
l'acqua non sono anche come tra l'altro
avrà veramente non c'era non c'era modo
non c'era verso di cadere sono caduto
yes proprio lui conti sixty che prende
il traguardo al 43 vabbè ma di qua
ok comunque non abbiamo più visto se ci
sono pezzi che puoi fare anche senza
fatti tutti dalla mappa prima tv ho
capito che doveva intendersi pareschi
fare ma li stessi e non credo dia
c'erano neanch'io
no no no amiche siamo fortissimi sto
giro buono questa era facilissimo nostro
tifo era facilissima la mia vita e
pietre cade cioè tu tono del tosto ai
per la peta m che ribalti della strada
su una ragnatela in un altro livello di
vederci come è stato divertente come ti
sei incastrato in una ragnatela
aspetta acqua proprio rimbalzo supremo è
molto supremo questo rimbalzo con cavani
che di farlo con camera di farlo un'arma
un cazzo è vicinissimo ma tu l'hai fatto
un paio di volte sì ma poi sono morto un
paio di pure non caldo lo facciamo un
cane muoio secondo me io io lo fa
ricorrendo e fanno correndo ad ora
amiche non so cosa dirti come hai fatto
fallo dolore quando uno è forte è forte
ma va a cagare va correndo concerto
subito
ok ok avete aspettato il cavolo li
dentro ok amato saltare dall'altra
parola non devo stare di velocità no è
no perché portano che occhiate di quel
che ho visto è tutto a posto
se un pazzo sono pazzo ma va bene
provaci no io ho speso prova non
provarci non provarci che io ho
aspettato ci sono ok e mo che capito a
jean scala un fire sono fire mani
sbatter sbattere perché fai a fare un
giretto veramente uniche gite sintesi le
città che possono forte proprio lui che
sogna così i ragazzi non c'è poi il
successo fuori non c'è aiuto aspetta non
c'è pronunciarmi che e non c'è c'è poi
ti aiuta quindi non mi dice che sono al
potrebbe essere un 44 e mezzo cerchio
della scarpa della scarpa esatto
la prima garri comiche come cacchio si
parla scusa mimì gravissimo ok c'è un
buco guaio brave vieni qua a b che vieni
colli e di una mano a mano a mano
peccato dalla io no no no no non è vero
non è successo quello che sto pensando
no non possiamo dire quale tu sì però io
non posso morire quattro amiche sono al
44 il livello io no non è vero non è
vero non è vero
[Musica]